[Música]
muchas gracias buenas tardes es un
placer estar aquí en este escenario así
que mucha gente está esperando que hoy
yo hable de como yo pasé de abogado a
comediante
yo estoy ya se están riendo yo no he
hecho chistes que talentoso soy
entonces y la gente me lo pregunta
sorprendido tú antes eras abogado y
ahora eres comediante como si fuera tan
diferente yo
igual yo sigo viviendo del cuento
entonces
si fue una etapa que requiere muchos
sacrificios yo trabajaba en una oficina
de abogado y estaba acumulando
vacaciones y entonces para luego de
graduarme irme de viaje por un buen
tiempo y entonces estaba tomando un
taller sobre planificación legal de
negocios y todo el mundo participando
tanto y tan y tan emocionado y yo tan
desubicado en ese taller y ahí no sé por
qué me llegó a la idea dos imágenes
freddy beras goico y gear design felt no
tienen nada que ver uno con otro pero
bueno lo hacían reír y entonces ahí fue
la primera vez que yo pensé yo quiero
ser comediante porque no me gustaba el
derecho pero no tenía un plan b yo no
pensé nunca en mercadeo ni en publicidad
ni en administración yo solamente sabía
que yo hacía me gustaba hacer chiste y
ahí fue que la vi como una posibilidad
profesional entonces fue una etapa de
sacrificio porque yo ahí renunciando a
la oficina vendí mi carro y me fui de
viaje y en el viaje gaste el carro
andaba por europa entre dice bueno en
italia ya te lo coma
y así yo iba consumiendo el carro volví
para acá sin carros sin trabajo y sin
saber lo que iba a hacer
en esta etapa bueno empecé con mi esposa
empezamos el noviazgo mis amigos me
decían vamos a salir a beber una cerveza
yo no podía porque yo no tenía dinero ni
para pagar la cerveza y me daba
vergüenza ya que me siguieran brindando
mi esposa me pasaba a buscar me llevaba
al cine me pagaba el cine me pagaba la
cena y me llevaba a la casa
me casé con ella tenemos dos hijos la
mejor decisión de mi vida la amo
profundamente pero ya tenía que casarme
con ella por compromiso moral por edad
sí porque ya ella me adoptó en mi etapa
de rudy o entonces es tan fuerte que ya
después de que ahora no bye bye entonces
se lo ganó básicamente se lo ganó
e
entonces comencemos esto pero y por qué
van tan rápido hijo un siervo de dios
darle para atrás ok
ay perfecto saif el saint feliz esto yo
empecé en el año 2002 estoy premium no
existía existía pero no tenía el agua
que tenía ahora y entonces la única
referencia de estando que yo yo sabía
que quería hacer humor pero no sabía qué
humor y me acordé de todo americano que
se paran y hablan y
y entonces yo digo bueno aquí nadie está
haciendo eso déjame yo probar eso y
entonces la única referencia era shine
felt saint phalle en su serie empieza y
termina con él haciendo un momentico de
stand up sobre lo que pasó o pasará en
ese episodio y entonces por lo tanto
comencé a estudiarlo arduamente
y ahí en una entrevista que yo escuché
de él
y le preguntaron por qué hay tantos
comediantes que hoy en día fracasan lo
intentan y fracasan entonces él explicó
lo que pasa es que cuando yo empecé en
los años 70
habíamos 3 gatos y nosotros teníamos una
sola prioridad que era hacer reír a la
gente
eso era lo único que queríamos hacer
está parado frente a un público tratando
de hacerlo reír fuera de eso no
pensábamos en más nada y mientras más
hacíamos eso más puertas se iban
abriendo y de eso de que yo quiero
hablar en el día de hoy porque hay
muchos artistas jóvenes o gente que
quiere
ser artista que se me acercan cada día
más diciéndome yo quiero ser cantante yo
quiero ser actor yo quiero ser director
y empiezan a decirme una serie de
disparates pero nadie me abre las
puertas nadie me da la oportunidad es
sale muy caro y yo no sé cómo empezar y
entonces ahí de eso que yo quiero hablar
hoy
y eso fue así porque yo comencé con ese
libro me compré ese libro en amazon que
se llama the comedy by vol
la biblia de la comedia ahí te explica
cómo escribir chiste cómo relacionarte
con el público cómo armar una rutina
etcétera etcétera pero hay un episodio
que habla de cómo manejar tu carrera y
tiene tres puntos que van muy de acuerdo
con lo mismo que decía shine fer el
primero es que te hagas bueno primero
que nada el segundo es que te conozcan y
el tercero es que te paguen ok eso es lo
último no piensen que te paguen si nadie
te conoce y no piense que te conozcan si
tú no eres bueno primero
y hay mucha gente que se pierde en ese
proceso porque qué se necesita para
bueno necesito esto ahora
por favor louis y que no me comediante
el favorito por ciento le doy a te aviso
louis y que ya está envuelto en un
escándalo sexual ahora
y es uno de mis comediante favorito y mi
comediante favorito de todos los tiempos
bill cosby que ahorita lo voy a citar
también
son mis dos ídolos y de repente me
entero que son dos maldito enfermo
por favor no no piensen mal de mí ok
ellos son influencia en la comedia
solamente
entonces luisi que aplica uno solamente
puede llegar a ser bueno después de
pasar por muchos show malo a ti te tiene
que ir mal muchas veces y esa es la
mejor forma de tu formar un comediante
valga la redundancia entonces un
momentico a esa entonces mucha gente que
me dice eso mismo me dice yo no sé cómo
empezar
yo he tocado la puerta de tal sitio y me
dicen que no yo he sometido mide muy
nadie me dice que no entonces aquí vamos
a pasar varios sly de corrido edith piaf
viking continúa rod work
tracy chapman 3 brosnan continúa
tremendo comediante también bernie mac y
robin william para lo ahí todos ellos
que tienen en común todos ellos
comenzaron en la calle todos ellos
empezaron en parques en plazoletas en
calle peatonales como en el conde a
cantar a veces a capella a tocar la
guitarra a hacer teatro de calle a hacer
chistes y la gente le echaba moneda y
así porque empezaron todos ellos que
recurso tú necesitas para hacer
0 con eso tú puedes ahora mismo sale
allá afuera y a la primera 5 personas
que te encuentre tú puede empezar se le
cheat y ese tu primer show de humor
cuando yo empecé yo hice show en toda la
fiesta de mis amigos que me invitaban en
algún momento yo decía ok ahora yo voy a
empezar a hacer chistes y ahora me toca
y casi siempre era bienvenido pero había
veces que era carlos ya toy jarto por
favor ya te te oí ayer y antes de ayer
ya cállate y yo lo entendía pero yo
quería hacerlo chiste y entonces
entonces y también ustedes pueden ir a
su iglesia y antes le dicen al párroco o
al padre por favor ellos regalame 10
minutos usted sabe padre que yo hago una
interpretación de jesucristo y usted
como actor
usted como actor se sube y hace una
interpretación de subtítulo más que el
padre le puede decir es no vuelvas a
esta iglesia
o si no puede ser que te diga el domingo
que viene por favor hazlo de nuevo y ahí
ya tú estás practicando frente a un
público
miren por ejemplo el sfe de álvarez él
es uruguayo el es director de cine y él
hizo una película de cuatro minutos y
medio que está en youtube que se llama
ataque de pánico donde unos
extraterrestres atacan
montevideo él le costó un par de cientos
de dólares lo hizo y él hizo todos los
efectos y todas las cosas
y lo llamaron ahora de hollywood porque
esa película le gustó y ahora lo van a
contratar en hollywood para hacer
director en hollywood con que él empezó
con nada con su computadora su
imaginación y 200 dólares entiende y
miren lo que hizo él no espero que nadie
le abra la puerta él simplemente subió
algo en youtube porque él lo hizo y se
le abrió esa puerta
lo perfecto es enemigo de lo bueno y
todo artista joven tiene que tener esto
muy pendiente todo el mundo oído muchos
amigos que me dicen no quiero tocar
hasta no grabar mi disco no quiero tocar
hasta conseguir la banda perfecta y no
entiende que es simplemente arranca a
tocar no tienes que esperar nada todo
eso que tú dice que tienes que esperar
no es verdad que lo tienes que esperar
este es conan o'brien que ustedes lo
conocen lo más seguro para mí uno de los
mejores anfitriones del programa de late
night es que hay ahora mismo el es un
entrevistado si hubiese esperado que
todo mi programa estuvieran perfecto y
hubiese hecho siete mientras tanto yo
tengo que hacer un programa de lunes a
viernes todos los días el de hoy no
quedó bien bueno veremos mañana vamos
hablar qué fue lo que pasó y mañana será
otro día pero hay que seguir trabajando
lo perfecto es enemigo de lo bueno
por favor
ok y ahora esto es algo muy interesante
gente que está empezando en el arte yo
lo veo muy selectivos empiezan a
llamarlo para ir y hacer cosas y me
llaman me llamaron de tal sitio que tú
quieres debo de hacerlo y mi respuesta
siempre es que claro entorno si hay
confianza le digo claro idiota bien pero
por lo regular lo dejó en claro
por favor
miren
yo pienso que esta frase ha sido una de
las que más daño ha hecho piensa en
grande es una frase muy dañina porque la
frase no está completa la frase tiene
que ser piensa en grande
no importa si arrancas pequeño es la
salvedad que hay que hacer me encanta
esta frase de martin luther king la que
usted va a pasar que dice no tienes que
ver toda la escalera solo mira el
siguiente escalón te lo voy a aplicar un
poco como fue mi recorrido yo empecé yo
yo empecé aquí en los falafel y ese bar
y eso ahora es un hotel de cinco
estrellas para cuando yo arranque yo
arranque en un momento que era un
cuadrito así que habían 30 personas y el
escenario estaba en un segundo piso
literalmente y te quedaba ahí el
escenario o sea que tú tenía que verme
ahí y la gente llegaba a la casa con
dolor de barriga por la risa y dolor de
cuello
duraban una hora así y ahí fue que yo
empecé después de una larga negociación
con el árabe dueño de esa empresa
yo logré que en el primer show para
garan 800 pesos
para los que no son de aquí tengan una
idea esos son como 17 18 dólares segundo
yo me pagaron mil pesos seguir
presentándome ahí y ahí toque la puerta
de casa de teatro
obviamente freddy ginebra lo único que
sabe decir claro que sí muchachos ven
adelante yo no sé para que él sigue
trabajando hace rato que se ganó el
cielo ya descanse y no fuma más
entonces claro
entonces ahí en casa de teatro me
empezaron pagando tres mil pesos y yo lo
llenaba todo lo llevo con mis amigos y
mi familia yo duraba semanas de la
semana llamando a todo el mundo por
favor vea mi show
y entonces luego en uno de sus shows un
señor se me acercó mi familia me había
apoyado y yo me dijeron okey tú quieres
es comediante pero yo duró un tiempo que
no sabía lo que iba a hacer y estaba en
mi casa como bueno pensando en la
inmortalidad del cangrejo y una mi
familia me enfrentó y me dijo que tú
quieres el comediante está muy bien pero
tiene que serlo o sea que sale allá
afuera y haz comedia entonces en uno de
sus shows se me acercó un señor y me
dijo te voy a contratar para mi
cumpleaños para que vaya a mi casa y
haga chiste para mi familia y mis amigos
me pagó tres mil pesos y yo recuerdo mi
hermana que en ese momento ella me dijo
arrancaste esa fue la única palabra que
me dijo los que me van a contratar para
3000 pues ella me dio arrancaste eso era
todo lo que tenía que hacer empieza a
que la gente te vea
en casa de teatro me subieron a cinco
mil pesos y luego siguió creciendo y la
gente seguía yendo y me subieron a seis
mil pesos entonces
entonces el que administra eso es jose
arístide que está por ahí y yo sabía que
si le seguía pidiendo aumento le podía
dar un derrame entonces
le vamos a cambiar la estrategia y ahí
quedamos acuerdo de que la gente pagaba
taquilla y la taquilla era mi pago y
ella el bar no me tenía que pagar la
primera taquilla costó 50 pesos la
segunda taquilla costo que hicimos que
costará 80 pesos y el mesero de casa de
teatro me dijo cuando la gente pague con
100 vacío un lío devolverle 20 pesos
entonces
o paga con 50 o cobra 50 o cobra 100
entonces ahí mismo subimos 100 pesos
y esta empresa está creciendo rápido
porque
en un día subimos dos veces a casa
eso me dio un buen augurio entonces
subimos luego 200 pesos y subimos luego
a 300 pesos y ya después de un año más o
menos de presentación y de tenía
suficiente monólogo escrito por mí para
hacer un solo show grande el primer mi
primer especial de stand up y ahí fue
que hicimos carlos sánchez mucho gusto 4
5 y 6 de noviembre del año 2004
y eso fue 500 pesos la taquilla y luego
cuando llegamos a la casa estábamos
contando el dinero de esos tres días mi
esposa mi novia ahora mi esposa pero mi
novia
no somos una familia tan abierta
mi novia ahora mi esposa y mi mamá y yo
ahí era que quería llegar
pusimos todos los paquetes de papeleta y
yo tenía en el piso 90 mil pesos y yo
juré que yo había robado yo nunca
cuando yo y repase mi agenda de a todos
los sitios donde yo había ido me di
cuenta que no había robado en ningún
sitio entonces ahí pensé que fueron
ellas los que robaron
y yo dije malditas ladronas voy a las
mujeres en mi vida que me dijeron no nos
fuimos nosotros que robamos entonces me
di cuenta que yo nunca había visto una
cantidad de dinero así eso fue para mí
eso fue como loco en serio yo no sabía
que alguien por aceite le podían pagar
esa cantidad entonces a dónde iba
no veas toda la escalera solamente el
siguiente escalón yo lo que quería era
presentarme y luego de presentarme yo
voy viendo el siguiente paso el
siguiente paso el siguiente paso y
solamente va creciendo poco a poco
cuando uno se pone una meta muy grande
eso es muy abrumador y eso causa
parálisis eso hace que tú no sabe como
at&t como que te piden que tú abracé un
árbol que tiene tres metros de diámetro
tú no vas a lograrlo entonces tú te
abruma igual ese tipo de meta muy grande
entonces piensa en grande pero arranca
pequeño y no importa si arranca pequeño
entonces esta señora se llama young
readers ella es famosa porque era uno de
los más trabajadores de la industria de
la comedia justo antes de morir ella
seguía haciendo gira y se presentaba
muchísima noche ella no paraba el
consejo que ya le da en una entrevista
que le daba a todos los comediantes
jóvenes es dile que sí a todo y es un
tremendo consejo dile que sí a todo no
le cierren ninguna puerta le voy a dar
un ejemplo
en lo que yo estaba empezando un amigo
me dijo yo te voy a celebrar mi
cumpleaños por favor a chistes en mi
cumpleaños y ya no era dica el chiste
entre amigos prepara un show le hice un
show en su cumpleaños y ahí había un
argentino ese argentino es amigo de otro
argentino que trabaja en buenos aires en
el programa de televisión en ese
entonces más importante de argentina
me vio en ese cumpleaños un par de días
después habla con ese amigo le dice
estoy organizando un festival concurso
de humor y no tengo ningún representante
de república dominicana y él le dijo yo
acabo de ver un muchacho en república
dominicana y yo tenía como un año
haciendo comedia y una semana después yo
estaba aterrizando en el aeropuerto de
ezeiza en buenos aires además de que
conocías el lindísimo país
estuve en el programa de televisión más
importante de argentina con una
audiencia que es una locura y todo
porque porque un amigo me dijo tú puedes
ser mi cumpleaños y yo le dije claro que
sí cobra lo que es lo que tiene que
decir todo artista joven claro que si
buscas y aquí yo veo tanta gente que
busca razones para no en vez de razones
para si abre puertas ese tu única
prioridad ahora mismo cuando está
comenzando
entonces creo que ahora sí viene exacto
estará en el otro por el vertido pero
me da tanta pena loco por en serio
independientemente de todos sus
problemas legales que tiene ahora yo
considero que él es el mejor de todos
los tiempos y mucha gente está de
acuerdo conmigo no soy el único que
piensa así casi siempre está dividido
entre richter prayer y bill cosby hay
gente que dice que george carlin pero
este tipo de verdad para mí es es único
es lo mejor que ha pasado por un
escenario para mí una de la frase del
que te la otra parte que paraliza a
jóvenes artistas es la crítica de lo que
van a decir de ti que te van a criticar
que todos y hay una parte muy importante
que deben entender te van a criticar no
importa lo que tú hagas o digas la
crítica no es un obstáculo es una parte
es parte del camino eso viene entonces
no traté de evitarlo porque no lo vas a
lograr
una de las frases que me encuentro
buenísima yo no sé cuál es la clave del
éxito pero la clave del fracaso es
tratar de complacer a todo el mundo
entonces le voy a poner este ejemplo yo
por un tiempo hice un resumen de
noticias de manera cómica con cavada
entre las noticias y entonces eso vídeo
yo lo subía a youtube aquí yo voy a
decirle algunos de los comentarios que
ponía la gente en esos vídeos de youtube
miren los primeros tengo eso fue un
chiste de que yo decía llegó poco en vez
de llegó papá por un tema pero bueno
llegó popo ja ja ja
mira ja ja ja nunca me he sentido tan
emocionado por ver las noticias
ja ja ja carlos tú te pasas a diego popo
siguiente genial carlos por un monstruo
wow ja ja sigue así esperamos más
este señor es una toyota que no sabía
nada sus chistes
madres abrió y me mató
yo no sabía que yo podía causar cuasi
suicidio
por el último comediante que yo pagaría
sería por este desafío yo le puse abajo
trata entonces de que alguien te regale
la boleta
me avisas y la consigue ojalá no veamos
a ella
otro show de este desafío en este país
político malo empresario malo periodista
malo y [ __ ] comediante malo disculpa si
ofendo a alguien pero alguien debe
decirlo este me encantó porque no
solamente que yo no le gusto sino que él
me ve como parte de los problemas del
país
[Risas]
qué profundo se fuerte [ __ ]
y ja ja y este este es mi favorito este
si es un desafío de padre y madre lo
llena regalando boletas y ni así voy yo
a un show de este [ __ ] fui a uno por
una cajita que me tenía loco y con todo
y que me gustaba mucho la dejé sentada y
le dije cuando se acabe me llama y te
paso a buscar si quiere y ella misma me
dijo vámonos yo creía que era otra cosa
esa noche yo la resumo como un maldito
fracaso básicamente
la crítica en mi caso claro está
yo puedo usarla como por ejemplo pasó en
este caso
entonces gracias también tengo haters
además de fanático tengo haters que los
giros son gente que no le gusta tu
trabajo pero ellos se preocupan de que
tú lo sepas
más básicamente es la definición de un
hater alguien que quiere que tú te
enteres y entonces alguien me dijo
cuando hicimos la película el que mucho
abarca alguien me escribió en twitter
puede ser que como actor la pegues
porque como comediante eres horrible y
estoy yo le dije no sé si sentirme bien
o mal y era la verdad porque la parte de
comediante quedó clara ya yo sé que yo
soy horrible pero en la parte de actor
ella me dijo puede ser que la pegó o sea
que yo no sé si le guste o si no les
guste si me dejó con dudas y entonces le
dije no sé si sentirme bien o mal y ella
me respondió las críticas negativas nos
ayudan a crecer así que nada de sentirse
mal o sea que ella misma me apoyó y me
trajo en un solo tweet
la mejor gente del mundo en serio fue
como que ella me dijo todo eso pero
palante muchachos
en el caso mío tengo
que puede ser parte de mi trabajo pero
y que todo artista joven
todo está bien tiene que tener en cuenta
que lo van a criticar entonces ya
terminé y vamos a concluir a todo aquel
que quiera ser artista y estar en un
escenario que está tan equivocado por
viven tantas cosas que necesita grabar
un demo chulo un disco comprar mejores
instrumento y tener una mejor banda todo
eso está equivocado aquí entonces yo
creo que lo puedo resumir de esta manera
concéntrate en ser cada vez mejor en
aquello que quieres ser es el primer
paso como tú lo logras con el segundo
paso haciendo muchos lo que quieres
hacer el tercer paso el momento perfecto
no existe deja de esperar y siempre
recuerda que esta frase lapidaria que
dice al que espera y espera le ponen el
n
[Risas]
la número 4 no te traje metas grandes
solo traza la siguiente meta eso es todo
lo que necesitas hacer la quinta es si
se te irán abriendo puertas diles que si
a todas luego vendrá el momento en que
empezarás a decir que no y empezar a
pensar en decisiones estratégicas
mercadológicas etcétera yo por un tiempo
tuve por muchos años luego contraté un
asesor mercadológico y ya él era el
encargado de decir que no yo siempre
quería decir que si él decía no eso no
nos conviene por tal razón pero eso fue
yo tenía ya por lo menos siete u ocho
años siendo comedia cuando él empezó a
trabajar conmigo
pero mientras tanto olvídate de eso
tiene que decir que sí a todo y por
último te van a criticar no lo veas como
un obstáculo sino como parte del camino
espero que les haya ayudado
[Aplausos]